bonjour je suis vraiment ravi d'être
parmi vous ce matin merci à vous tous
avouent tout je suis une femme arabe
soit disant du sexe faible
une femme qui a grandi dans un pays où
les femmes ont toujours joué un rôle
dans tous les secteurs
ce pays et la tunisie je me présente je
suis vidé de bouchamaoui je suis
tunisienne après l'indépendance nous
sommes entrés dans une ère de progrès
pour les droits des femmes pour
l'éducation et pour la santé ces progrès
ont été menées par un leader habib
bourguiba qui a donné à la tunisie un
niveau développer un nouveau
développement très important
l'ombre de la dictature s'est étendue à
ériger des murs
à cet instant le peuple tunisien se
retrouver dans la rue vous exprimer le
peuple tunisien croit en un meilleur
avenir
il demande la dignité la démocratie
le travail c'est la révolution
c'est la révolution du jasmin c'est
notre révolution
je me retrouve également propulsé à la
tête du patronat
première femme à être élue à ce poste
dans le monde arabe
la lueur d'espoir dissipant en partie
des ténèbres
oui des murs tombent et l'ombre
persistent encore avec le retour des
islamistes aussi en grande partie à
cause la fragilité du système politique
économique hérité de la période ben ali
qui a clôturé tous les secteurs pour
mieux les contrôler crise politique
grève à sa cianas la déception
nous avons eu peur pour leur évolution
du principe du chaos né la vie et voilà
que quatre organisations de la société
civile s'allient pour dissiper les
ténèbres l'utica le patronat tunisien du
gtt du syndicat des travailleurs la
ligue des droits de l'homme l'ordre
national des avocats
ils oublient leur ego ils sont là aider
le pays
le patronat que je représentais avec le
syndicat des travailleurs ont mis de
côté leur ego pour sauver la révolution
et surtout le pays
c'est alors le début du dialogue pour
éviter une guerre civile
cela a été long et difficile
plus de 1500 heures de réunion 24 partis
politiques des menaces de morts et un
nombre incalculable de va et vient
d'ailleurs vous avez de quoi je parle
mesdames courir en talons les faits
pendant plusieurs heures
la feuille de route et l'a signée par 21
partis politiques une constitution
moderne des élections législatives
présidentielles libres démocratiques
transparentes avec une participation
massive des femmes pourront créer leurs
acquis c'est la nouvelle tunisie
c'est le succès de la transition
politique dans le pays
la crise économique persiste encore mais
je reste convaincu que nous tunisiens
sommes en train de changer les choses
notre révolution note à 7 ans elle est
encore jeune la tunisie est cité comme
exemple pour la réussite sa transition
démocratique
partout dans le monde nous brandissant
l'étendard de la tolérance de la paix
nous nous alignons contre les préjugés
contre les injustices et pour l'égalité
entre hommes et femmes
toutefois la femme musulmane reste
jusqu'à aujourd'hui une ombre
on se méfie dont on a peur je ne
comprends pas pourtant nous aussi
devrions être cité comme exemple en
effet en tant que femme arabe musulmane
nous prison des murs nous mettons à bas
départ hier la femme arabe musulmane
peut être président du patronat la femme
arabe musulmane peut sortir non voilée
la femme arabe musulmane peut être
également lauréate du prix nobel de la
paix c'est le meilleur souvenir je pense
la wii représenter la tunisie
représentée les femmes tunisiennes
représenter la société civile par les
très hauts
la femme arabe musulmane on ne peut pas
rêver d'un meilleur cadre de vie tout
comme les murs peuvent aussi être
symbole d'espoir pour nous pour la
jeunesse arabe musulmane on croit en
notre avenir
on croit en notre capacité
je vous remercie profondément pour votre
écoute merci à vous tous et à vous
toutes et merci du fond du coeur surtout
à toi selim au revoir merci